[Music]
Serena Williams and Alexis Ohanian just
threw their daughter Olympia a surprise
Moana party just because we just try to
have a lot of fun on Wednesday we
learned just how far Serena will go
after she shared these snaps to
Instagram showing off a little
celebration the couple threw for their
five-year-old daughter
[Music]
that's the happy fam posing it up with a
balloon arch and an actor dressed as
Moana the occasion absolutely nothing I
was told live your best life and that's
all I can do is live my best life and
have fun Serena captioned the post quote
sometimes we surprise Olympia with
parties we don't need a reason or a
special occasion we make every day as
special and memorable as we can the most
rewarding thing is just seeing her smile
every day it makes me so happy and she
wasn't kidding earlier this month Alexis
shared a clip taking the breakfast game
to a whole new level making Princess
Daisy pancakes with his little girl
and on Christmas Day the proud dad
posted this video of a pancake he made
shaped like a hamburger but Olympia she
wasn't impressed
[Music]
by piece Olympia
Alexis also revealed the over-the-top
Christmas gift he and Serena got for oh
a pony posting this snap alongside the
caption I surprised Olympia with a new
member of the farm family yeah it's
awesome safe to say Serena and Alexis
love being Mom and Dad in fact back in
2018 the tennis pro opened up about how
having a child changed her life for the
better it's been amazing I've I never
I've always wanted to be a mom you know
but I never seem to have time I was
always working with my career and then
it just happened and I was just like I
don't know and I just Dove right in it's
so natural for me
um I love it I love her so much and you
know we have a great little family going
on earlier this year Serena told Vogue
that she was evolving away from tennis
without actually using the word
retirement she explained that part of
the reason why is that she wants to grow
her family without worrying about
competing while pregnant but she's left
the door open to return to tennis I have
my priorities in Olympia is that I'm
never a day without Olympia like she's
my priority and every day I like need to
be home with her because I don't I don't
want to miss any moments with her
[Music]